So the first technique for reducing the
miss rate is using larger cache blocks.
They help the miss
rate because more words
are brought in when we have a miss so
subsequent axises
that might access those additional words
that we brought will not be misses.
And they would be misses if we
had the smaller cache block.
So this does reduce the miss rate, but
only when spatial locality is good.
But when spatial locality is poor,
the miss rate will increase,
because now what happens is we bring
in the word we need, and along with it,
now, we bring more words that we
didn't need, so effectively our cache
now looks like a lower capacity cache
because it has more junk in it.
So, we end up suffering more
of those capacity misses.
So, if we plot the miss rate and how
it changes as the block size changes.
For a small cache we might
get something like this.
Where the miss rate drops as we
increase the block size, but
then starts increasing as we exhaust
the amount of spatial locality
that the cache can support.
But then it starts to grow
as we start to suffer
from the miss rate increase because
there is not enough special locality.
For a 4KB cash, this might happen for
example with the block size of 64.
Interestingly however,
for larger caches,
we will start out with the lower
miss rate to begin with and
it will continue to drop
up to larger block sizes.
Eventually, it's going to
start to increase.
But here we might be looking at for
example, 256 byte block size.
This effect has to do with,
how much junk
are we putting in the cache, and
how much room there is in the cache.
So some blocks will have
more locality than others.
And then in a small cache,
those that don't have enough spatial
locality are creating some junk.
And those that do have a lot of spatial
locality are being placed in the cache,
but there is not enough room for
them because of all the junk.
When we have a larger cache,
for example 256 KB,
then what happens is
those blocks that don't
have enough locality put some junk in
the cache, but the cache is bigger.
So it can also contain those blocks
that do have spatial locality, so
the cache tolerates
a slightly bigger block size.
Overall, we can reduce the miss rate,
especially in a larger cache
if we increase the block size.